Hi everyone.
Welcome to talk to Google today.
It's my pleasure to introduce Justin
Lynn and John Cho for star Trek.
[inaudible]
aw, thank you guys for
being here. Thank you.
And other you for being here.
Oh,
I was wondering what he was holding the
a communicator to communicate it. Yes,
I'm familiar with that.
I pay attention.
That's fair. Um, Jesse, do you wanna
tell us a little bit about this film?
Can I see it? Um, the process?
So, sure. It was about 18 months ago
almost. Exactly. Um,
I was shooting something in Ventura and
my phone rings was Jj Abrams and I never
met him before and we just
started talking and he said,
do you have any connection to star trek?
And it was a really cool talk and he,
I said, okay, well I'm shooting.
So it was a Thursday. I said,
let's meet up on Monday. Let me
think about it. And, uh, and I,
I remember driving home
just thinking about,
I knew star trek was part of my life,
but I never thought about
maybe like participating in
the franchise, you know. Um,
and it was a really cool
drive. And I, at one point,
I just decided to call my
parents and I said, hey, look,
can I just have dinner with you?
So I drove there and we had this great
dinner and was at that moment I felt like,
let's do it, you know, I mean,
at the logistical challenge that was
ahead of me and the team was insane.
Like, you know, I,
I do the fast movies and they used to
be two years to get that from idea to
delivery. And that's insane. And
here it's 18 months, you know.
And so the next thing I knew,
I'm,
I'm on a plane to London with Doug and
I'm in the hotel room with Doug and Simon
and Lindsey,
and there was no idea and we had
to get something by June. Um,
but I think it was really, it was
really great exercise because, um,
I felt like it was a worthy challenge,
you know, and, and everybody in that room,
even though it was like really
relentless, uh, we love Star Trek. And so,
um, that was, that was our starting
off point. And I felt like,
especially with 50
years, uh, of Star Trek,
I felt like if we can kind of really
kind of deconstruct or try to deconstruct
why we love it so much
through these characters,
then hopefully by the NL reaffirm our,
you know,
the passion that's been there and
hopefully we can contribute to the legacy.
Where did you eat?
What was that dinner I had,
I remember Simon Simon was eating
this healing with your parents.
Oh, they, they, they, they
know I like, I'm healthy.
I don't eat really healthy, but
they, they think I eat healthy.
So they like steam a lot of vegetables
and like go crows and stuff like that.
This is a year.
Is that how house
painting at ut you're healthy you have to
hit, yeah. Yeah. That sounds good. Yeah.
Um, speaking of characters we love, John,
you have been with this sort of iteration
of the cannon for a while now. Um,
what was it like stepping
back into the shoes of sue?
Uh, it's always, it's
great. I, I consider it, uh,
an honor to put on the uniform and,
um,
I've always admired star trek.
Uh,
as a piece of American popular
culture that's, you know,
uh, put forth something, um, you
know, but the idea is that it is,
spouses are a beautiful,
and I feel like it's a,
it's a worthy piece of
culture to be associated with.
And so I take it seriously and,
um,
it feels great to put that uniform on.
And then there's obviously
a team of people that I
really loved working with the
cast of course. And, um,
and then I was reunited with Justin this
time around. And uh, so that was very,
very special
for you. Was it sort of
interesting you, you know,
the last time Justin is at
the helm of one of your films,
it was probably on a much smaller scale
and slapping their buck credit card
movies,
just different limits.
That was,
that was a diners club card
and this was a mx black. Yeah.
But,
um,
but I was, I was remarking
that in, in a lot of ways. Um,
I saw Justin's independent
spirit come out in this. I mean,
he just described that he had
a truncated a timeframe and,
you know, uh, they went in and,
and he had to start making decisions
without having a completed script. And so,
you know, just from when I'm, when we,
when we had that initial
meeting at paramount and you
were working on stuff and
then I could see the gears
going and you were, uh,
making gut moves, you
know, and think, well,
I know that we have to do this.
That's what I feel.
And then we will have to write around
these three or four decisions that he had
made early on. And so, I mean,
that's an unusual way to
work at this scale, you know?
But it was kind of great seeing,
seeing what I felt, I mean,
from my vantage point was sort of an
independent spirit and improvisational
spirit, uh, colliding
with this giant thing.
Yeah. So it was very exciting,
a little dangerous. Um,
little scary, but
eventually, uh, I mean, I,
I saw the movie eventually satisfying.
I think your stamp is very much on this
film and in a great way. It's, it's,
I think we're seeing things we
haven't ever seen in star trek before.
And some of it's just because you know,
technology,
but I think a lot of it's
due to your influence.
So what were some of your favorite things
that you were excited to bring to this
sort of beloved?
It's funny because, um, I
grew up engaged in, you know,
my parents had this little fish
and chips restaurant, you know,
and they close at nine and
we'd have family, family
dinner at 10 and, uh, you know,
Star Trek came out 11 back in La,
you know, and, uh, my brothers and I,
we'd talk our way into staying up with
them. And so from eight to 18 hours,
our family time, you know, our
engagement was on the original,
the original series and every night.
And so my,
I remember even as eight
years old, I didn't understand
the, the notion of reruns.
So my, my like, so filing when I
saw the episode repeated, you know,
it didn't make any sense to me, you know,
so it was, it really was a great kind of,
uh, environment. Um, but
I, I think because I,
my engagements offer reruns, um, by
the time I saw it like the fourth time,
the fifth time, um, I kind of wanted
to fan fiction mode, you know,
because every, it's this, the
show is so compelling and fun. Um,
but I've always wondered,
well,
what happens to Sulu and Chekov when
they leave the bridge, they hang out,
do they like each other? You know,
like little things like that.
And so in constructing this movie that
I wanted to at least explore that and at
least be able to showcase some of that,
you know,
and that that to me was aside
from all the actions and stuff,
those for me on a personal
level where the most rewarding,
sure. To note that I'm pretty
sure Sulu is taking a selfie
that's a modern sooner the
selfie survives into the, um,
no, I think, I think you, you
hit on it like a great point.
Like for me that's a very
shared experience actually
because that was the only
thing we were allowed to watch growing up.
It,
star trek or sesame street
creates a very weird,
like sense of what the
television landscape is as a kid.
Yeah. I was, uh, you know, the first
time I started thinking about, well, I,
years ago,
I don't want to brag,
but I did a showtime movie
called the Tiger Woods Story.
I played Jerry Chang, uh,
his Stanford roommate.
Okay.
And, uh, did a lot of research, um,
but, uh, Lavar Burton director of that
movie and I was, I remember being really,
really impressed because he was in roots
reading rainbow and star trek and I was
like, this guy is, uh, making
a mark on American culture.
And I meant very seriously,
you know, and uh, anyway,
so did dovetails into, uh, my
admiration for the franchise.
I think it's the same,
it's like these,
there are only so many things
in our lifetimes that have
this level of impact on
such like a global scale. And like I, I,
I just think star trek is one of
those things. It speaks to everyone.
I think everyone identifies with
a different thing in it. You know,
for some of us here we are at Google.
I'm sure a lot of people are, no,
I'm tech tech and TV, like star trek is
inspired so much of real technology. Yeah.
Um, so what would you say, like
some of the things that you really,
really identified with, um, work
a first for me it was, um, you
know, um, I'm an immigrant a,
um, and we immigrated to Houston, Texas.
And, uh, as a kid, I'm watching
this show in the early eighties,
or there just wasn't anyone else on
television that looked like me. Um, Eh,
you know, except for like Kung Fu theater,
which loses, who's a disappearance.
I bemoan, but, um, uh,
but aside from that,
it was George and he was in a
cast in a heroic light if limited,
you know, on the show. It was, it
was heroic. He was on a spaceship.
And, uh, so that was just
a momentous for me and I,
and, and I didn't realize how important
it was until really later. But,
um,
that's my first memory of it.
Yeah. For me, I remember we,
we had just immigrated also to the states
and it was just my parents and me and
my two brothers. And, uh, it
was, it was Kinda, it was,
it was a bit scary trying to like you
halfway around the world and you'd have to
learn the English, you know, new
language and everything. Um, but I,
I remember kind of watching
star Trek and real,
I think that family kind of
goes beyond blood. You know,
it's, it's a, it's a group,
people coming together going
through the shared journey and, uh,
that really had a really very
powerful can imprint on me.
Yeah. And I think it's, it's an ideal
that we're still struggling with,
sort of working towards,
but it's nice and it's nice to have a
star trek movie coming out now. You know,
we're not in the greatest of times.
It's nice to sort of have a reminder of,
I think this film does a good job
of being like, yeah, it's like,
hope there's hopeful. Um, John,
I want to go back a little
bit to something you've
just said is, um, you know,
I think, uh, the Asian representation,
like I don't want to go too much into it,
but you know,
starring John Cho was such an exciting
thing to see because it's like, yeah,
and you're starring in
this, you know, it's,
it's nice to have you continuing that
mantle and, um, I think it's, oh, thanks.
Uh,
I'll ask myself a question.
How did you feel?
Yeah, it was crazy. Um,
oh, we, which is an
example of, I mean, uh,
I'm not just kissing ass
cause I'm a Google, but, uh,
it was like a strange moment of,
um, populist expression that
happened online, you know? Um,
I, I don't know, you
know, if we could have,
if that could have happened,
uh, in 1990, you know,
I'm, I'm assuming not, um, or any,
how it would have happened
in 1990, obviously. Um,
so it was brilliant.
It was simple and I always thought it
was interesting that that guy used the
tools of, um, movie makers. You know,
we just sometimes, you know, if
you go to the American film market,
they'll just have a poster of,
you know,
Stephen Dorff on a jet ski and it's
called, you know, uh, you know,
terminal snow and the, the,
the script isn't written yet.
And some Russian guy,
we'll plunk down, you know,
7 million a and say, okay,
write me the script. I mean,
they present the poster before they
write this screenplay and, and because,
because it's a really effective way
to sell an idea, you know. And um,
and the starring John Cho thing was
just a bunch of really well done posters
that got people talking.
The, the most interesting,
I read an interview with the guy, William
you who, who started it and he said,
um, the most interesting
thing he said was, if,
if you find this funny,
you should ask yourself why.
Um,
there was no question.
So I haven't technically failed to answer.
I think you asked the question that I
realize that I'm just fluttering calls.
No, I think it's a, it's like a question
that we should still be asking you.
And the other side of it.
It's also very nice to have representation
behind the camera. Um, I think it's,
it's nice to see,
you know,
directors of color and it's exciting to
see something is epic is this, you know,
have that sort of influence.
And I think, again,
it's going back to like the
roots of Star Trek, you know,
and it's not just Asian Americans. It's
like you have Nichelle Nichols, you have,
you know, all these sort of
groundbreaking things. And, um,
I just appreciated seeing
sort of diversity again in
this star trek movie and
not just the ones like humanoids.
I'm,
the thing I was super impressed
by was the aliens on this. Um,
you did some stuff with the aliens
and I was just so impressed by,
and it's no longer,
you know,
we've come a long way since just your
painted green in a body suit and that's
suddenly you're, you know, a sexy
alien lady or something like that. Um,
did you always know that you wanted
to include such, like a wide berth of
Oh yeah. I mean, I, that was one of the,
uh, the perks of the job, you know, and,
and Joel Harlow, who did it
such an amazing job. I mean,
as soon as I signed on know,
we were looking at a different creatures.
We're looking at the history of trek and
you know, especially with crawl, like I,
you know, interest elbows,
Keller character. Um, it,
it was really interesting because we
really want it that designed to embody 50
years of trek creature. So, you know,
cause the nature and there's
a twist you guys, you know,
it's the whole thing is that,
you know, we want it to, I mean,
we wanted to make sure that
as we were designing it, uh,
we were very mindful of
the history, you know. Um,
but I also feel like the
aesthetic now with filmmaking,
we have more tools now than ever in
cinema. And it's, especially with like,
um,
visual effects and CG and it really kind
of has a vault to its own aesthetic.
And it was,
it was cool to kind of try it.
One of the goals is to bring this
tactile nature back into film.
So it was really cool to go in the shops
and would've like molding it and stuff
and you actually can feel and touch and
build these characters. You know, I was,
it was a lot of fun,
John, for you. Was having like
it visually show that like the,
the sort of nature of like,
Hey,
there are a lot more buttons this time
and aren't just like pads, like for you,
did that help you even more get into
this sort of further iteration of Zulu?
Uh, I don't, I don't prepare
that much. Um, all right.
I'm not that serious of
an actor. Uh, but yes,
I mean that it's,
that the enterprise is like a very,
um,
maybe it's because of all the mythology
surrounding it and all the culture
surrounding it.
That's like a,
it's an obviously recognizable pieces
is very a cathedral like for me,
you know, and then, um, so it's something
I've known. It's something very familiar.
And then,
uh,
to come on this on the new bridge is
a strange because it's new and old.
Um, and the bridge is just, it's
very easy to pretend there. Um, and,
uh, I'm a limited, I'm an
actor with limited range,
so I need as much help as possible and
everything seems to do something or you
can believe that it does.
Thanks. So, no, I was
impressed though. I mean,
I'm the Newbie here and when I walked
on to you and Anton and everybody,
it's like they just go into
it and they're in that mode.
I believe that I believe. Good. Thanks.
That's beautiful. Uh, Justin,
you did, you did a very short for
us. You did a great story. What,
was there anything sort
of you learn from that,
that you brought to star trek with you or,
well, what I loved about that
experiences, um, I didn't want,
I want it to be fully immersive and,
um, a lot of times, you know, I,
I feel like as a filmmaker I'm
always looking for areas to, to trim,
prove and try to grow every day, you
know, and with the fast movies, um,
that aesthetic was something that I,
it was out of practical,
um, interaction. You know,
like I would come up with crazy ideas
and all these great people that's crass,
people around the world come in
and try to make it happen. Like,
but there'll be like the weirdest
little thing where I'm like, okay,
it's going to,
the car's going to crash and the
land and I want to lay down his roof.
And they'd never land on the
roof. Never. You know? Um,
so like editing,
always kind of like you always ended up
doing one or two extra cuts. And, uh,
the thing doing the VR was I really
wanted to challenge, you know,
because it was going to be live
action and to do it with no cuts. Um,
that took a lot of prep, a lot of people
coming together to bring that to life,
you know?
And,
and the thing that I learned about that
is there's some really talented fucking
talented people in this world. So if you
could think it, everyone's going to come.
And, and that passion just
drives it. It was so inspiring
because, you know, I mean,
if you have to really think about it,
live action going like lights,
cast shadow and then yet how
are you going to do three 60.
But like if you just have an idea
and you present it out there,
it's amazing how like a group of people
come together and make that come into
reality, you know? And so, um, I
really appreciate it. You know,
I felt like I was in like editing
crazy editing world for awhile, um,
which is my own doing.
And I really loved that experience
because there was no cuts, you know?
So that really dovetailed into
this film where I, there's,
there are a lot of moments where I
think also because the cast is so great,
you know,
where I can just let the camera flow and,
and there's a sincerity
about that, you know, I think
edits are great, but it also,
it's cheating, you know? And
so people that get that, uh,
and to be able to have that kind
of controls, it was pretty amazing.
Speaking of the cast. Uh, so I have
to ask about the Dubsmash thing.
Who started that? It officially started
with, uh, if you don't know, uh,
we had just had been, do you
know the APP? Dubsmash? Uh, no.
It's a lip syncing APP. And, um,
Zoe started at Zoe Saldana started it,
um,
and it got really out of hand and
we spend all our time doing it.
And then we had a Dubsmash, um, uh,
crisis because,
um,
we were texting them to one another
and the weekend we really started in
earnest. Um, we, I mean,
I think we'd done like 80 all together
and there was on this super long text
chain except, uh, Karl urban
was not, uh, who plays bones,
was not, um, uh, texting back.
And,
uh,
which was weird because
it was like very him.
And when he came back to work
that Monday, we said, uh, we,
we've been weeds Dubsmash
Dubsmash and he's like,
what are you talking about?
And we realized that we had been
texting an old number of his,
um,
to a production cell phone that he
had a while shooting the last movie.
And it had been going
to a landscape architect
and we were very scared
because, uh, you know,
Sophia was doing stuff in makeup,
full hair and makeup and,
uh,
there's a lot of secrecy around these
movies and we were revealing everything.
There's a lot of evidence
and uh, anyway, so,
um, it turned out it was uh, yeah,
so, uh, we thought that Carl was,
um, effing with us and
um, but it turned out he
was real and we had to
call him this man and a,
beg him not to, uh,
since sell these things.
Um,
he was very cool.
And did you not participate back?
Cause that would have been,
I wish, I hope we sent him a
bottle of Scotch or something.
We'll take audience questions in a minute
if folks want to line up. Um, okay.
I some sort of rapid fire questions
for you guys, uh, for both of you, um,
for you in real life. Not Relating to any
character of you have made a plate. Um,
engineering science. There's
security department, red shirt,
yellow shirt or blue shirt.
Okay.
Generics, science, science.
Is there an arts department?
Um, if you had B one alien species
within start talking about, would it be,
I, I would, I would love to be strong and,
uh, like a Klingon. Okay.
That sounds good. Clean on. Okay.
What's one piece of technology from the
Star Trek University you'd like to see
realized sooner rather than later?
Like a holodeck.
Replicators warp drives.
I mean the food stuff, right? Like
the applicators. Right. That's,
that's pretty cool.
She ain't chick filet in space
chick filet and Sushi guys.
You've got to try that. We survive post
productions, chick fillet and Sushi.
It sounds really healthy. Um, would
you rather deal with the Mirror Mirror,
alternative universe version of
yourself or a triple infestation
mirror Tribble that that's,
that's there's something about masses of
something that's very nightmarish to me.
Yeah. Bumps. I said I'm scared of bumps.
Okay.
Um,
who from the cast do you think is
actually most qualified to run a startup?
Wow. Simon. Simon Parr.
Yeah, but you know things.
Zack, is he so believable?
He like when he jokes around
like it takes me like 10 seconds.
So even laughed because I realize
that it's Zach and not Spock.
I go show up on set, he has a band job
cause he's always probably things banjos.
I'm like, wait, Spock holding
a banjo, that's still,
it's still having a hard
time getting used to.
That's certainly something that would
probably be very visually disconcerting.
Um, well speaking of that, uh,
the Internet is kind of an interesting
place for fandom and what's probably the
most unique piece of Fan art you've seen?
Yeah.
Oh yeah, the Spock Kirk
stuff. Oh No, I was,
I just in general,
fan fiction gets gay fast,
you know, I'm sure there's
some like nice, heroic. Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Going south real fast.
Um,
do either of you have like a sort of
Kobayashi Maru story where you kind of
cheated the system a little and,
and yeah,
this whole film was a Colby
when I signed up. I don't know what
happened before me, but you know, it,
all I know's Jj came to the call and
you sit, hey, go make it your own.
Be Bold and just do it. Go.
And then once I took it every,
I wanted to be ambitious
in every idea I had.
It felt like we didn't have enough money,
you know,
so I felt like we were back into
doing their big indie movie, you know,
and that like, we got sequences
in the movie where, um, you know,
we need probably 20 more days, first unit
in 20 days, 20 more days, second unit,
you know. But we would do stuff
where we'd shoot first unit,
everybody would go home and I'd stay
and shoot second unit all night and then
they would go home and the first unit
show back up and we shoot first unit all
day. But, you know, it was like that was
the process for this movie, you know,
it was totally worth it, you know, and
it was great. And, and, um, you know,
just everything like the, uh,
some of the sequences we shot,
like the motorcycle sequence was shot in
a day and a half. That was a total, like,
I used it, I literally smoke the
mirror out of that sequence, you know,
and I'm sending cameras
out and just shooting. And,
and it was just prepping and
using every trick, uh, up to, uh,
to this point in my life. I know I use
every trick on this, on his phone. So,
so at any point did you ask Jj Abrams
how he got your number? Like re
Jj Abrams just calling you?
It's kind of interest
saying like, you know, um, at
this point in my crew, like
sometimes the phone rings,
I just don't know who it is and you just
kind of pick up and it could be anybody,
you know,
it's kind of cool.
No, no, no accidental.
We'll go to our audience.
Cool. Thanks Justin. This
is a question for you.
You're a big star trek
fan and a big fast man.
So it was fun to see you're
involved in this project. Thank you.
Could you talk about
what it's like to try it?
When you create something that fans have
like a connection to something that's
familiar?
The challenge of keeping it familiar and
like making that connection for people
but then also making it interesting enough
that they want to show up at things.
He's something else,
you know, the reception. So far, I mean,
whether they like it or not, I think it's
hopefully they feel respected, you know?
Um, I remember when I, when I, you
know, jumped into the fast franchise,
I'm not a car guy.
I didn't know anything about cars.
I think have a better appreciation for
it, but that's not my passion, you know?
And so I remember I would go and hang out
with guys that were drifting and stuff
and, and really just hang
out all day and just hang,
like really trying to understand their
passion. He's like, I love basketball,
you know, but that's my passion. And
I, if, if, if I watch something, I,
that's basketball related, I hope
they are respecting my, so that,
that was what I learned through that.
And Luckily I think with Star Trek, um,
this is the original series is
based on the original series.
And I do have a love for maybe different
at different levels, other people. But,
um, that's something that
I think we were very, um,
I was very clear on, I mean, when
you do this, you know, especially at,
at this budget level,
you know,
you really do feel like that's where
the art and commerce just collide.
And some of the meetings you go in and
the fights that you have to, you know,
really go. It's pretty
intense, you know. But I,
I feel like at the end of the day that
that first meeting I had, uh, not with Jj,
but with the studio was very clear
what we were going to do. You know,
I think sometimes when you get in a
room, people are like, oh, you know,
it's been 50 years.
Should we try to make star trek
more like this or more like that,
or more like this. And, and I just felt
like that was the wrong approach. Like,
we have the goods, you know, Potter Star
Trek's about these great characters.
It's about this,
you know,
really the shared journey and the
sense of exploration and discovery,
you know. And, uh, and part of the
mandate of star trek is to try new things.
So I really felt like it
was all there and, and,
and sort of trying to be something else,
like let's really kind of find
them within and, and, and, and,
and really celebrate that.
I will, amen that by saying,
I mean this is not bs. He, he,
he did talk about the fans
during production all the time.
And it was this constant, uh, I mean it's,
it's helpful just on a practical
level too, for as an actor, you're,
you're pretty self centered.
And I mean,
I mean like internal you'll
focus is internal. And um,
one of the, the sort of spines he
kept coming back to was what did the,
what would the fans want?
And it is this like a constant
thing that you would hear from Jeff?
I think that there'll be clear too,
it's not to pander to try to understand
why there's so much passion. You know,
like again,
I come from the fast world and sometimes
people think fast and it's just fast
cars, good looking people. And
you're like, well, if it's that easy,
the studios would make like 10
of them every year, you know.
But it's not that easy. I think there's
an emotional connection that we have
and, and the, and that's a
relationship that's very dear.
You know, and I think, uh,
but part of that relationship
is also sometimes having to put,
put it in uncomfortable places,
maybe challenging certain
notions. Um, and that's,
I think that's part of the fun
of, of, of doing being a part of,
of something that's so special.
We saw it with sort of a mix of people
who are maybe only familiar with the
newer ones and people who've
been watching it since forever.
And I think everyone felt like they had
a good time for those who have been with
it. Like, you know, the characters longer.
It felt respected and really enjoyed.
And I think there are wonderful little
nods to the sort of those of us who've
watched the original series
and watched it through. And,
and yet it's still really like
inclusive to new audiences.
So thank you so much for joining us
today. Go See Star Trek. Thanks guys.